c'est un fameux carnaval je vous prie de
le croire le carnaval de granville une
institution depuis 1872 du temps où il
s'agissait d'une grande fête avant le
départ des pêcheurs de morue pour 7 à 9
mois en mer des festivités d'origine il
reste le sacrifice de monsieur carnaval
les chars les confettis les costumes le
tout très inspiré par l'actualité
yannick noah en 1984 après sa victoire à
roland-garros ou bien le duel hollande
sarkozy en 2012 même si le carnaval
accueille de plus en plus de visiteurs
il a gardé une tradition qui elle ne
concerne que les grands vides et la nuit
des intrigues dans l'après-midi les rues
se vident
chacun rentre se déguiser de manière à
ressortir incognito charles hauss à
aller devant pas mal garé dans la soirée
les ans et les autres vont se rencontrer
échanger sans savoir à qui ils ont
affaire et les chats des intrigues on se
permet de raconter un tas de choses
qu'on n'oserait pas normalement si vous
étiez démasqué toute la nuit
c'est un jeu de rôles faire deviner à
l'autre qui on est à grand renfort
d'anecdotes
[Musique]
ou bien s'inviter chez des voisins pour
une plaisanterie haut niveau mais de la
sorte la plus belle robe de chambre
[Musique]
encore aujourd'hui la tradition permet
de sortir de sa fonction de sa
personnalité
ça peut être aussi par exemple avec des
voisins ou avec son patron j'ai pas dire
de régler ses comptes mais parfois de
d'aller voir des gens qu'on peut ne pas
oser aller voir le reste du temps et là
en l'occurrence au pôle faire aux
intrigues du jeu et de l'humour dans un
carnaval par définition populaire et
festif chaque année cent mille
spectateurs célèbrent l'événement à
granville inscrit depuis 2016 au
patrimoine immatériel de l'unesco
[Musique]